what I'm anticipating though is it
obviously hair is kind of a big deal to
me not to be too basic but I hear that
there's like some hair to look forward
to your part Oh giving your hair a run
for its money oh yeah
well so tell me every yeah I don't think
if I grow it that hair I could not give
his hair for a run for its money because
he has a great head of hair mine sold
paste it on it's not red so around the
sides is a mullet wig yes I lots of fun
it was great fantastic how is life
different with magnificent business in
the front and a party in the well I look
I feel like I never knew what I was
missing and now I know how you two feel
in life every day I have yeah I had I
had the mullet for six months like a
real mullet
yeah it's just I'm just a simple leading
man I can actually get weird about it
but like I see it in person now and I
just hear like Eagles and land you know
we've had a lot of arguments at Rotten
Tomatoes about the demagogue and and
like what's gonna happen this season and
did it disappear last season was it
actually defeated so in theory let's
talk about any famous movie or TV
monsters that could put the demagogue on
down
oh I mentioned this earlier the Balrog
big mean I like that I think so just
monstrous it's big yeah yeah you know
what occurred to me because I was
feeling smart for a second was the
Jabberwocky get like a little Alice in
Wonderland okay maybe it's the thing
that's hard is like yeah we don't really
know entirely what we're dealing with
here yeah that's the thing
what the range in that thing is yeah I'm
beginning a hornet's nest your nose and
if we can hear the sirens in the
background my ride is here
[Music]
so my lick when I imagine you guys
shooting this I would assume that it is
a lot more fun to be on set than it is
scary it's like all these like intense
scenes ever supposed to like everyone's
supposed to say something and we're all
supposed to be like seems like we shoot
all together you know we kind of pieced
up blobbin you get us all together they
cannot just get like one usable tape is
there anything that's happened on set
that was truly strange like yeah like
something that seemed really unusual or
memorable well I know is that I got
faked an almost all the way up the back
of my leg inside put on for one scene
and that was strange enough for me for a
day so you can wait to see that yeah
wait like I wanted to wax my chest
yeah strange do you do it twice twice I
got away without it nice yeah I know
it's like the same I was going to say
sometimes this the strangest thing is
just you know the nature of filming
anything that's kind of like you know
out of this world sci-fi you know the
you there's moments where you catch
yourself going through actions or like
you know yelling or like looking or you
know doing all these reactions you're
just like what is like what is for me I
was like that tree scene last year you
know just like a home like getting
covered in goo in the middle of the
woods in the middle of the night and you
just have that's just like what like
it's just you know these weird amounts
of like how did I get here like in real
life like what am i doing this
[Music]